what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
so at the time of this recording the
rumor is that the Fantastic Four will
not travel to Disney when they acquire
their huge chunk of Fox whether that's
true or not I don't know honestly the
deal hasn't been announced yet so I
honestly have no earthly clue I would
like to believe the Fantastic Four would
go with Disney when they buy Fox but
there's a possibility they may not so
because that we're just gonna go ahead
and throw out like phase one anyway
regardless we're gonna treat it as if it
does go out there now with regards to
the Fantastic Four in phase one this is
actually shorter than the x-men in phase
one where the expert in Phase one was
more like eight or nine movies this is
more like six for those of you guys who
are familiar with the Fantastic Four
which is to say comic book readers this
part of the video goes out to the non
comic book readers so bear with me for
the next you know a few minutes or so
while we run over this so the Fantastic
Four are probably the most important
superhero team in the history of Marvel
Comics and this is for a variety of
reasons but the biggest reason is
because of the fact that in comic books
there's two types of characters and/or
teams there are characters that do
something new and there are characters
that build on that they're basically
sort of you know add their own little
additions and tidbits to it team based
books had existed for years before the
Fantastic Four they go all the way back
to DC Comics in the 1940s with the
Justice Society of America of course in
1960 you know DC published the Justice
League of America and that team has
proven to of course been a lot more
popular than JSA just because of the
writing was better and because the the
team consisted of more popular
superheroes it was really kind of like
the creme de la creme of DC at the time
but in 1960 Marvel Comics was a new kid
on the scene I mean they were the new
guys for the most part I mean you had
timely publications and timely
publications existed back in the 1930s
but by the time World War two ended you
know superhero popularity had basically
died out who is replaced by science
fiction you know the war great war was
over people wanted to focus on
exploration and aliens and science
fiction and all different kinds of
things and so because of that DC shifted
their focus now timely shifted their
focus and they became Atlas comics and
they started publishing a lot of science
fiction things but by the time there was
this resurgence and the comic book scene
which is to say the appearance of very
Alan the flash in 1956 it brought in
what we call the Silver Age of comics we
call it that because it's just this
second age I mean it's just called the
Silver Age for whatever reason and the
whole idea was that Marvel needed
something to pop because of you were
come
reader in the 1950s you were reading DC
Comics DC had launched the Teen Titans
they had the Justice League you know you
had Batman Superman Wonder Woman if
Marvel was going to get the attention of
comic book readers and bring them from
DC over to their publications they
needed something that hadn't really been
done before and so what they did is they
gave us the Fantastic Four on the
surface the Fantastic Four is a team
book it's no different than any other
team book we've seen before
save for one thing family squabbles and
that was something that we hadn't seen
you hadn't really seen a superhero team
that was composed of a family and they
bickered and they argued and they fought
they had the same kind of stereotypical
family squabbles that people gave all
the readers experienced in their own
families brothers and sisters arguing
husbands and wives arguing different
things like that anyway it was amazing I
mean Fantastic Four exploded onto the
comic book seemed like nothing before
and because of the popularity of the
Fantastic Four
that was the premier title of Marvel
back in the early 1960s 1961 1962 and so
what Marvel did is they said if we're
going to start introducing more
characters then we're gonna do it a
couple of different ways either we're
gonna do you know anthology series like
Marvel premiere and Marvel presents and
everything's like that or we're going to
put them in the Fantastic Four in some
former fashion spider-man was kind of
the kind of the exception spider-man of
course game is huge you know popularity
and amazing fantasy number 15 the first
teenage superhero to be the main star as
opposed to a sidekick but even he teamed
up with a fantastic for it he actually
tried to join the team and they turned
him down which is kind of funny the
x-men because they weren't that popular
they teamed up with a Fantastic Four the
Avengers teamed up with the Fantastic
Four
Black Panther debuted in the Fantastic
Four and so did the Inhumans that's how
Marvel did things that's how popular
they were they were the foundation by
which Marvel Comics was built now the
reason why I went to that whole little
rant was because I want you guys to
understand the significance of the
Fantastic Four being brought into the
MCU this is the first family of comics
the success of Marvel in the 1960s lived
or died by the Fantastic Four and that's
just the way it was and so because this
we have to treat the Fantastic Four in
the MCU with as much importance as the
legacy they've built over the years
having said that the first movie is
simple it's straight and to the point
just like it needs to be it's just
called the Fantastic Four we're not
calling it fan for stick or anything
like that like Fox did we're just
calling it
Tasik for now we run into our first
problem when it comes to the Fantastic
Four not their powers but Reed Richards
himself and Marvel Comics Reed Richards
is the smartest person in the Marvel
Universe for the most part I mean
usually he might switch spots with like
you know Victor Von Doom depending on
who's writing the story or even his
daughter Valyria Richards if you were
following Jonathan Hickman's Fantastic
Four so we can kind of say that given
the full publication history of Marvel
as a whole that dr. doom Reed Richards
and Valeri Richards share the top three
spots for the smartest people in the
Marvel Universe but the biggest problem
we face with Reed is that if he's the
smartest man in the universe how do we
reconcile that with the fact that
nobody's ever really referenced him
before now we could go with the ultimate
universe origin Reed Richards as a young
kid he's a prodigy he's super
intelligent he joins a think tank
eventually goes on to form the Fantastic
Four and you know everything else
unfolded in the Ultimate Universe in my
mind we need experience Reed Richards I
say we go with the adult version of Reed
Richards who of course to be played by
John Krasinski I don't know why you
would you know cast anybody else but
John Krasinski look at the guy man he
looks just like Reed Richards look at
him side-by-side looks just like Reed
Richards I think John Krasinski would be
a great Reed Richards his wife would
make an amazing Susan storm but we need
experienced Reed and if we're gonna go
with experience Reed it means he's been
around for a while we're talking about a
guy who's in his 30s most likely maybe
closer to 40 so we got to talk about a
guy who's experienced how do we have
adult Reed Richards who's the smartest
man ever
and we haven't referenced him before
that is a circle that I haven't been
able to square yet I've been thinking
about it in different ways and I kind of
figured well we might be able to go the
amazing spider-man route there was no
reason to believe that Peter Parker
existed in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
prior to the events of Civil War we saw
him in Civil War and then he got his own
movie and that's it but the difference
is that we could easily chalk that up to
the idea that Peter Parker's only been
around for about six months as
spider-man up until that point he was
just a kid who was living in New York
and his uncle died now was it I mean we
could really do a lot with that in terms
of sweeping it under the rug with Reed
Richards we can't so we kind of have to
figure that out so I'm gonna leave that
to you guys actually I'm curious what
your thoughts are on how we roll Reed in
and justify his existence in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe while being the
smartest man in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe
but in terms of their powers it's
actually pretty simple so the whole the
overall plot of this film the overall
core of this Fantastic Four film would
be just like the x-men and this
that it comes out of infinity war and
finiti war is going to be the sort of
jumping-off platform for the Fantastic
Four in the MCU and what we do is we
bring in the organization sword now in
Marvel Comics you have a variety of
different groups that exist out there I
mean you've got like factor 3 for
example you know as an old x-men villain
team didn't perform to you well but they
appeared back in x-men number 28 they
were created by Roy Thomas I think was
back in 1967 or something like that
of course factor 3 was directly tied
into the success of spider-man sinister
6 which appeared back in amazing
spider-man annual number two in 1964
you've even got organizations like the
hand you know this old-school Japanese
mystical Society the the history of the
hands actually really cool to sidetrack
for a second the hand was originally a
group of various people who broke away
from the existing Japanese government or
organized society more or less and then
basically took to the mountains to
practice their own sort of you know
philosophy and martial arts they were
all brought together by a guy named cog
and Nobu Yoshioka I think and then he
branded he brought them all together as
a singular team they started worshipping
the Beast
and then the Beast basically gave them
the means to do things like resurrect
people from the dead but there's a lot
of organizations sword
it stands for sentient world observation
and response department war shield
monitors earth sword monitors space and
that's exactly what you do you do this
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe in
agents of shield they referenced the
concept of sword in the sense that they
made sort of a joking joking comment
about if somebody asked agent coulson
you guys don't have something like spear
or something along those lines and he
suddenly answered said no I mean we
never really had a reason to monitor
space before but following the events of
infinity war following the idea of
Thanos showing up on earth most likely
the Avengers going out into space and
realizing there's all these races that
exist out there making contact with the
guardians of the galaxy meeting group
meeting rocket racoon so on and so forth
Drax the destroyer there's a lot of
things that you can do with that
assuming that drachez origin is not
Arthur Douglas from Earth but the idea
is that the federal government responds
by saying because of the fact that this
guy Thanos showed up on earth conquered
the entirety of the Avengers just
wrecked them without trying at all we
need to have some sort of equivalent to
shield that monitors space inter soared
from there by whatever manner and
whatever means we chose to introduce
Reed Richards you have him lead the
first mission of soared into space to
basically explore or something along
those lines the ship goes up something
goes awry Reed Richards Susan storm
Johnny Storm Ben Grimm have to
back because they're blasted by cosmic
rays or something like that the result
is that they crash land on earth and
they have powers we do not need Disney
or whoever to tell us they're the
Fantastic Four that's the name of the
movie we know what they are we know what
the name of the movie is and so
following this you kind of let the
viewer sort of figure out what might
happen next in the immediate something
along those lines but for the second
movie you transition to what will
probably be one of the most anticipated
characters in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe following Disney's acquisition
of Fox that character of course being
molecule man now it's messing around
that character of course being Doctor
Doom now of course Doctor Doom is one of
the most notable villains who is out
there in Marvel for a lot of different
reasons
the most prominent reason was actually
fleshed out during Jonathan Hickman's
Fantastic Four and of course we saw in
that story which you'll find down in the
description that the various versions of
Reed Richards from across the multiverse
every single time their universes
version or a universes version of Victor
Von Doom became a villain they would
capture him they would lobotomize him
and they throw him below the Citadel
because according to their logic there
is no one like Victor Von Doom who is as
dangerous as he is doctor dooms quest
for power is insatiable if he sets his
mind on gaining absolute power he will
go to the ends of the world in order to
make it happen dr. doom has done this on
a variety of occasions doctor dooms
stolen the power of Galactus dr. Doom's
had the Infinity Gauntlet dr. doom has
had the Cosmic Cube dr. doom has had the
powers of the Beyonder a nigh omnipotent
being that comes from a cosmic you dr.
doom had the power of the beyonders
basically the race that this original
Beyonder hailed from who were virtually
unstoppable and wiped out all the cosmic
entities and Hickman's run on Avengers
and New Avengers leading up to the
collapse of the multiverse dr. doom has
always been able to acquire massive
amounts of power and even in his base
level he's easily equivalent to Doctor
Strange when it comes to mysticism and
all those different kinds of things and
so because of this if we're gonna do a
movie about Doctor Doom it has to be
solid it has to be strong and so that's
why I say we do not go with Stan Lee and
Jack Kirby's Doctor Doom origin in
Fantastic Four annual issue number two
what we do is we pick up with Edie
Brubaker's miniseries that was called
the books of doom and the books of doom
literally detailed the origin of Doctor
Doom in spectacular fashion from the
time that he was a little
his mom sold her soul to the devil from
the time that you know his family was
ousted from the local village traveled
to the United States when he first met
Reed Richards when he started picking up
a magic and mysticism when he became the
leader of Latveria all these things that
went into the development of his
character the philosophy of how he views
himself how we've used the world and how
his people view him it's all fleshed out
in the books of doom it's one of the
best stories ever written about his
character that needs to be as Origen
call it doom but the idea to me is that
it needs to be a strong origin for the
character because we're not really gonna
have time to flesh out the story of
Doctor Doom following you know the the
future movies that we have in the MCU
for the Fantastic Four now following
this movie you know we only do our third
film and the third film is actually
pretty strong and it's kind of
interesting some folks may say I'm sort
of jumping the gun there's a reason why
I chose this the third film that we
choose for the Fantastic Four in the MCU
is the original Galactus trilogy and the
reason for this is because again this
expands on the Marvel cosmology so far
all we really have are whatever alien
races that we've seen in guardians of
the galaxy we have the guardians of the
galaxy themselves and we have fan
awesomest black order and that's
probably gonna be about it whatever else
we end up getting you know an infinity
war and Avengers for whatever expands on
that maybe some cosmic entities not
really sure it's too early to know but
we're going to basically be seeing
somewhat of an expansion when it comes
to the greater cosmology with the
Galactus trilogy it expands it even more
and you play it out the way that we're
used to seeing it you play it out like
the original story you know you have
Silver Surfer who arrives on earth so
hey guys Galactus is coming y'all are
screwed Galactus shows up you begins a
process it's starting to consume the
planet pays no mind to any of the earth
superheroes doesn't care about them
doesn't listen to them doesn't do any of
that stuff Galactus for the most part in
the film is a backdrop you don't really
flush him out that much instead what
this does is it establishes the Galactus
is a force that's so extreme then he
doesn't care about any of the earth
superheroes the Fantastic Four
team up with the Avengers possibly the
x-men depending on how far we are in
their cinematic universe you basically
show that Galactus is this force that
cannot be stalked by any conventional
means on earth that's when you bring in
the watchers you don't have to go into a
great big huge thing you can easily pawn
it off you can just say this guy is a
watch of The Watcher the Watchers - took
a vow of non-intervention they just
watch everything unfold and you tie that
into infinity war you
want to basically look at the earth
superheroes and say I've seen you guys
fight against Thanos I've seen what you
guys were capable of I believe that you
guys will go on to do fantastic things
and because of that I've decided to
intervene the tool you need is the
ultimate nullifier point the men
direction of where to find it the
ultimate nullifier is revealed to be the
same thing it is in the comics it's this
device that if use can wipe out
virtually any being in existence up to
and including the universe itself Silver
Surfer turns against Galactus after
talking to you know the superheroes are
what have you the Fantastic Four the
Avengers team up against Galactus Reed
Richards comes back with the ultimate
nullifier the day is won and that's
basically it but what this does is it
allows you to begin rolling the Silver
Surfer in to the MCU instead of giving
the Silver Surfer a movie which I don't
think he needs what you do is you have
the Silver Surfer pop up in other
people's movies the Silver Surfer shows
up in the next Captain America movie
Silver Surfer shows up in the x-men
movie the next Fantastic Four movie and
all he's doing is having these little
cameos but the whole idea is that Silver
Surfer is coming to grips with what
people aren't he's learning to
understand humanity you get to see the
world through his eyes and it allows you
to bring in all these different
philosophies are superheroes really
doing the right thing are they fighting
a losing war what is the point of saving
people who don't want to save themselves
who would rather just stick their head
in the sand and wait for the problem to
go away that's what you bring in with
the Silver Surfer that's how he views
things and again that really helps to
flesh the character out but following
the original Galactus trilogy film from
here this is when you start building up
not only Galactus but the greater
cosmology you jump directly into the
trial of Reed Richards now in Marvel
Comics the trial of Reed Richards was
probably one of the most important
stories that involved his character and
the reason for this was because of the
fact that this basically detailed the
idea that Reed did not kill the lactis
when he had the chance and as a result
all these different empires and races
and organizations put Reed Richards on
trial for basically 80 in the deaths of
future billions because Galactus will
travel from one world to the other and
just consume them all in an effort to
maintain his own life force because of
this you end up learning all different
kinds of things about Galactus in this
movie that's when you start fleshing
this stuff out that's when you go into
the origin story of Galactus you talk
about how Galactus was a man named Galan
from a previous universe that universe
came to an end and he was
reborn as Galactus you can choose to
bring in things like the Phoenix force
and eternity if you want to de ciencias
of the universe merging itself with
gallant whatever is it you want to do
you can grab those super in-depth
concepts from comics or you can just
kind of do a rough rush over like we
talked about before you know he's just
born in a previous universe and was
reborn in this universe and that's
really about it but you talk about the
nature of Galactus you basically
illustrate exactly what Marvel data in
the comics that Galactus has no
definitive form humanity sees Galactus
is human because we're human but if
Galactus goes to the scroll homeworld
this Scrolls will see Galactus as a
scroll
if Galactus goes to the Kree homeworld
then the Kree will see Galactus as a
creep and so because that you start
fleshing all those things out why does
Galactus consume worlds what role does
it play you can bring the Celestials in
you can basically reveal that the
Celestials these beings basically
propagate their own race by planting
seeds and planets that are able to
sustain life Galactus consumes planets
that can sustain life in order to keep
the celestial population from running
out of control he has to be there that's
the point that you make the reason why
is because at that point Galactus stops
being this just villain who shows up and
oh my god the worlds in danger and you
humanize him because that's the role he
plays in the universe that's the
fundamental force he represents see all
these different cosmic entities have a
role to play Galactus is no different
and so following this you jump directly
into the aftermath of the trial of Reed
Richards with Reed Richards basically
being led off you know basically
everybody's saying hey look there's no
way he could have known Galactus just
showed up on his planet one day all he
knew was that there was this force that
was nigh unstoppable ultimately the
ultimate nullifier to defeat him this
whole trial of Reed Richards serves the
purpose of basically showing Reed
there's this massive universe out there
and so from that point Fantastic Four 2
is a space exploration movie now how it
is that you choose to explore space is
entirely contingent on whatever it is
that Disney and Marvel end up coming up
with I have no earthly clue but for me I
would make it somewhat of a montage film
in the sense that you would have the
Fantastic Four sort of going out they
would spend some time with the guardians
of the galaxy or they were traveled in
nowhere or something along those lines
that celestial head that's more or less
a Space Station they would visit things
like the kiln but you would do all these
different things you would show the
greater universe for what it is you
would see cosmic entities different
things like that it would just be a
matter of observation for Reed and the
other members of the Fantastic Four the
movie would be fun the movie would be
more of an adventure than anything else
it would break away for
the you know traditional serious movies
that we've seen so far and so following
this you would go into what I would
consider to be a story that would
officially lay the groundwork for the
Fantastic Four being rolled more into
the MCU than before because up to this
point all they've really have done is
fought alongside the Avengers in the
Galactus trilogy for this final film
what I would do is I would say if read
you know once they're done exploring the
cosmos once they officially come back
give all their information to sword
sword and turn takes over they use that
information and they begin the process
of monitoring the spaceways read comes
back home he sits down in his chair and
he says Humanity is woefully behind
there's all these things that exist out
there teleportation super advanced
weaponry and here's humanity surfing the
internet we need something better than
that we have to rise to whatever future
or whatever belief it was the watcher
thought we were capable of what we need
to do is look to the future what we need
to do is look to the children of this
generation and inspire them and drive
them to become better people and so what
Reed does is he gathers the smartest
kids in the world any forms what's
referred to as the Future Foundation now
the future foundation is this super is
super cool idea that was created by
Jonathan Hickman I'm pretty sure and the
Future Foundation is exactly what I just
described it's the smartest kids in the
world now of course Peter Parker became
a part of it at one point in time but
the Future Foundation was kind of this
overarching name where he basically had
this huge organization that was founded
by Reed Richards that was one part
Fantastic Four another part his kids
Franklin and valaria along with other
smart kids out there now Franklin of
course is the reality Warbler I mean
that's really what he is he works
reality on a cosmic scale I wouldn't
bring in those powers just yet I would
wait until like the second phase they
start talking about how Franklin is on
par with Galactus in terms of what he
can do instead I would focus a lot on
valaria the fact that she's basically
the smartest kid in the world I would
focus on Reed trying to make the world a
better place
that would be the whole motivation
behind it that would be the whole idea
behind it what that does is it puts the
Fantastic Four front and center to where
they need to be the Fantastic Four are
explorers first and then superhero
second a lot of us because of the fact
that in Marvel Comics you've got so many
other teams out there who engage in a
variety of different conflicts x-men The
Avengers you got all these different
groups out there that engage in battles
and so on and so forth and are always
there to save the day
when it comes to Reed he's like the
go-to source when people can't figure
something out when
you know beasts when hate McCoy from the
x-men can't figure something out he goes
to Reed Richards when Tony Stark can't
figure something out he goes to Reed
Richards time and time again people go
to Reed Richards you have them construct
Four Freedoms Plaza I would not have the
Baxter building yet Four Freedoms Plaza
was the original headquarters of the
Fantastic Four
before the Baxter building was built but
you could use the Baxter building if you
want to I mean just have them all
wrecked it and the sitting in the middle
of town but that's my vision for the
fantastic for each of these movies with
the exception of the Galactus trilogy
and the trial of Reed Richards each of
these movies are for the most part
disconnected separate one does feed off
the other but you don't have to have
seen one in order to understand the
other instead they're largely standalone
they focus on the intricacies of the
Fantastic Four as a team they focus on
the families they focus on how it is
that Chris Evans is playing both Johnny
Storm and Captain America at the same
time they focus on all those different
things when it comes to how it is that
this team works and what their place is
in the greater MCU so that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end if you are new here too comments
explain and make sure you guys have the
sub button to become part of the robb
cork if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and let me know
what you guys think down in the comment
section again you know this is just kind
of my view my vision my view for you
know Fantastic Four how I would do
things released how I would like to see
things done but at the end of the day I
have no doubt that whatever it is Disney
and Marvel Studios churn out with
regards to Fantastic Four in the x-men
it's gonna be amazing it's gonna be one
amazing ride to see anyway guys we're
gonna go ahead and bring this video to
an end and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]